your your dad
uh can you tell the story of
um of his struggle um
of his death remind me first
do you miss him do you think about it
all the time like
i had a son when i was 22. and i had ivf
three times and i as you see i'm like 80
pounds but back now like 75 pounds
because of my
massive malnutrition somehow my body is
very different
and so after three times of av
ivf after 23 i was still wanting family
and the reason i wanted him is
because i felt so guilty for my father
that he never seen this world
i somehow like when you're so desperate
you become illogical
like i want to believe in that i really
recurrence like buddhist idea right you
come back to life
and i prayed please come to me and i
guess my son so i will take care of you
like come back and when i was pregnant
with my son
even though i planted pregnant with the
girl doctor made a mistake
he became a boy so i made his middle
name
like my father's name since i think he's
the only american got north korean name
it is
so he's so part of your father isn't
your son yeah
that's how i that's how
i make the sense of it and that's how i
move forward
like if i like as a logical human being
you you you know when you're dead you're
done
maybe that's that's what i at least used
to think but then
life just become too unbearable and
somehow that's the thing like
we tell ourselves stories in order to
live and that's how i came with
my title of the book in order to live i
had to tell myself a lot of stories
to overcome a lot of things i think i
was part of it
you